jean-pierre toi qui as fait le miraculé
un drôle de paroissien ça te fait quoi
te retrouver dans un confessionnal
c'est un lieu que je connais bien parce
que quand j'étais petit vous allez me
confesser maintenant je me confesse lui
beaucoup je crois que c'est la première
fois que le mal qu'on fait ce depuis 50
ans
tu crois que tu es un mécréant
anat et plus tôt alors on va passer aux
sept péchés capitaux est ce que tu pèses
par orgueil non là je crois pas non je
suis plutôt trop pain blanc remarque
c'est une façon de drogués lui aussi
par avarice oui je suis radin ça tout le
monde le sait mais c'est parce que j'ai
pas eu de fric au départ
parce que tu sais que les deux
réalisateurs c'est sait pas très bien
casque et c'est pour ça
on est peut-être
la luxure par contre a beaucoup donné
non oui pas mal n'ont ils pas mal mais
ça s'arrête pas encore tous ces
championnats disait que quand il avait
90 ans
bon
il y allait toujours pu
enfin maintenant les partouzes du cinéma
avec le sida c'est un peu fini non à une
finition n'est pas une gêne à l'époque
ça c'est terminé maintenant tout le
monde a peur c'était quelle époque la
grande époque c'était 48 s'est-elle
existentiel il jean paul sartre les
bonnes femmes qui se font sauter par la
fenêtre dans le quartier saint-germain
l'arrivée c'était le début une fille
sortait de chez elle elle allait coucher
comme ça chez l'un chez l'autre ça a
commencé comme ça c'est sartre camus
tout ça qui ont mené sur cette impulsion
maintenant c'est un peu fini puisque le
sida c'est le ventre
tu as dit si on devait mettre bout à
bout les bassins de toutes les femmes
que j'ai sauté ça ferait 200 m tu es
fier de dire des trucs pareils oh non
c'est la vantardise est ce que tu feras
le divorce
j'ai fait un film en 66 justement parce
que j'arrivais pas divorcer j'ai mis dix
ans pour divorcer alors
pietro germi a fait divorce à
l'italienne ou tuer sa femme s'il
pouvait pas s'en sortir autrement puis
moi j'ai fait quelque chose qui
s'appelait les compagnons marguerite
avec claude rich cho lui il efface est
carrément les actes de naissance comme
ça les gens étaient divorcés
automatiquement le suicide on peut se
suicider tout en continuant à vivre
il faut faire quoi faire ce qu'on a
envie de faire je suppose quand on en a
marre de tout il faut faire n'importe
quoi mais parce que ça sert à rien ça
fait de la peine aux autres
est-ce que tu est favorable à la peine
de nous en avons tué trois mecs par an
dans la région du nord en général et
pauvre mec alors pour trois mecs
inspirant et la peine de mort c'est
vraiment on n'a jamais condamné à mort
ceux qui méritaient de l'être alors donc
finalement c'est des lampistes qui on a
exécuté pour la plupart même pour les
assassins d'enfants
ça j'aime pas
j'aime pas les assassins d'enfants ça ça
peut être que
faudrait les mettre dans un cas un peu
spécial particulier
je sais pas il faudrait lui parce qu'il
faudrait à fermer
la mort donnée la mort je ne sais pas si
quelqu'un est en droit de le faire et tu
favorable au droit de vote pour les
immigrés oui tout le monde a le droit de
voter ça sert à rien de toute façon tu
crois en dieu
je suis je t'ai dit que j'étais athée et
mais je crois à quelque chose mais je
voudrais bien savoir comment on a été
créée pourquoi je te parle en ce moment
je voudrais bien savoir qui c'est qui
m'a mis là
ceci dit ce mystère je ne l'est pas je
suis incapable de
découvrir de le déceler le percer à jour
alors jean merdé quoi je me dis quand je
serai cannes et qu'est ce que je vais
devenir
est-ce que tu n est tabou
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le
leader des tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu